president Trump reached out to voters
from The Oval Office last night saying
that the country needs a border wall to
respond to what he called an illegal
immigration crisis but first there is
breaking news this morning that could
affect the investigation of the
president's 2016 campaign sir is this
morning CBS News confirms that Deputy
Attorney General rod Rosenstein plans to
resign in the next few weeks for about a
year and a half he was the top Justice
Department official overseeing Special
Counsel Robert Miller's Russia probe
Paula Reed is outside the Justice
Department in Washington with the story
behind Rosen Stein's planned exit Paula
we've been hearing about this planned
exit for quite some time good morning to
you good morning Rosen Stein is expected
to leave the Justice Department in the
next few weeks around the same time the
new Attorney General William Barr is
expected to be confirmed now I'm told
Rosen sign always saw this as about a
two-year position and he wants to help
ensure a smooth transition but the
timing is surprising and it's unclear
what this means for the special counsels
investigation it's expected that bar
would likely inherit oversight of that
investigation but there's no guarantee
because his previous very public
criticism of that investigation is
expected to be a central theme of his
confirmation hearing next week all right
and Paula also this the other big news
about the special counsel now has the
clearest evidence to date that the Trump
campaign may have coordinated with the
Russians during the campaign what does
this mean for the president and the
investigation the president has
consistently denied that there were any
contacts between Russia and his campaign
but here we have the clearest evidence
yet that his campaign chairman had
contacts with a business associate with
ties to Russian intelligence and this is
exactly the kind of new information that
we expect will be included in Muller's
final report
well tidbits little pieces that don't
necessarily support criminal charges but
help be the picture of what happened
between the Trump campaign and Russia
all right Paula thank you that
development that Paul Manafort shared
pulling information with the Russians
that's the that's the key the question
is whether the president knew about that
whether that's the only piece of
information he shared or whether there's
more to come Russian associated with the
Russian intelligence not just a passerby